SRINI DEVADAS: Good
morning, everyone.
So we come to the end-- one
last lecture and puzzle.
Today, we're going to look at
a little coin row game and talk
about, obviously, an
algorithm to solve the game,
code the algorithm.
And I'm going to introduce this
notion of dynamic programming
to you which is an algorithmic
technique that's going
to be useful in this game.
Though it's not
essential to solving it,
it's going to be
important in improving
the efficiency of this first
algorithm that we come up with.
So the game itself is
very straightforward.
You have coins in
a row given to you.
So each of these has
different values.
And you can think of all
of them as being positive,
but it doesn't really matter.
And your job is to pick coins
to maximize total value.
And obviously, that's
not very interesting.
You just pick all of them
if they're all positive.
And if some of them
happen to be negative,
you wouldn't pick those.
So that's not
particularly interesting.
But it becomes much
more interesting
if you add the constraint
that if you pick a coin,
you can't pick the next
one, the immediate next one.
All right?
So if I pick 3, I can't pick 27.
If I pick 14, I can't pick
3, but I could pick 27.
So clearly, I can alternate.
Because I could pick, skip,
pick, skip, et cetera,
but I just can't pick, pick.
But I could go pick,
skip, skip, pick
if I wanted a value
that corresponds
to that fourth location.
So there's nothing
that's stopping me
from doing 14 and 4.
I mean, the only thing
that's stopping me
from doing that is I drop this
27, which is a large value,
and it seems like a bad idea.
But on the other hand, you can
think of a different situation
where you wanted 27 and 15.
And so maybe you want
to skip 4 and 5, right?
So what is the maximum value
for this particular puzzle
that you can come up with?
And what are the coins that
you would pick in this case?
Someone?
AUDIENCE: 56.
SRINI DEVADAS: 56.
How did you get 56?
AUDIENCE: By using
14, 27, and 15.
SRINI DEVADAS: You went 14, 27.
And then you went skip, skip.
You didn't want to pick 5.
You could have picked 5.
You can't pick 4.
But you decided that
15 was much better.
So you ended up
picking 15, right?
And if, in fact, you had
something like 11 here--
so let me just write that first.
So if you did that, it's 56.
And you're picking
14, 27, and 15.
So is that right?
Is that 56?
Yes, that is 56.
Good.
But if I had something
slightly different,
someone else tell me
what I should pick here.
What's the maximum
value and what should I
pick in terms of coins?
Yeah, go ahead, George.
AUDIENCE: The
maximum value is 57
if you just take every
other coin, starting 14.
SRINI DEVADAS: So
if you go 14, 27--
that's 41.
Now you want to pick
5, so that's 46.
And then you can't pick
15, but you get to pick 11.
And so you go 57.
Yeah, so this one was
alternation, pretty much
strict alternation.
So, well, you guys are
getting good at this.
So I'll give you a hard one.
Is that enough or
shall we go for more?
All right, this was the
final question, final exam.
You got 10 minutes--
seconds-- 10 seconds.
[LAUGHS]
So clearly, this
is not something
you want to do manually.
It's going to take a while.
There's a lot of
combinations here, right?
combinations here.
And if you do this,
you're going to go--
well, you can do
it in a greedy way.
You can say, I'll
just do alternation.
And so you go 3 plus 17--
you guys are going to
have to help me here
because these numbers
are going to get large--
but that's 20.
And then I can't pick 23, so
I go 20 plus 11, which is 31.
31 plus 4, 35.
35 plus 17, 52.
52 plus 34-- check
my math, please--
86.
86 plus 18 is 104.
104 plus 12 is 116,
is a possibility.
But at this point,
you have no idea--
I know, so I have some idea
whether 116 is the highest
or not.
And I'll tell you
that it's not, OK?
It's not the highest,
you can do better.
And you can maybe go and see
if you can twiddle things
here a little bit.
But remember that
you, obviously, just
don't want to drop something.
But if you just drop something,
you want to pick something up.
Because if you just drop
something, you'd lower 116.
And if you want to
do better than 116,
you absolutely have
to pick something up.
Especially when
you're alternating,
clearly, you could have done--
I mean, can you do
a little bit better?
My last thing that
I picked was 12.
And because of that,
you know what happened.
So can I do a little
bit better than 116?
Yeah, by dropping
12 and grabbing 15,
and I get a plus 3.
And you might think
that 119 is the optimum.
But it turns out that's
not even the optimum.
And so there's a
lot of combinations.
And I just looked
at something local
here to try and improve things.
But maybe I should--
you know, it's probably
was good that I picked the 34,
but I don't really know that.
I mean, it's possible that
if I hadn't picked the 34,
that I could've picked
the 23 and the 17,
and that is 40, right?
So maybe that was better.
So this is non-trivial.
This is a very simple--
at least to describe-- puzzle,.
But this is non-trivial in terms
of finding the optimum solution
as it gets
--longer, the row gets longer.
The numbers being large
is not really the issue.
It's the number of numbers
that's the issue, right?
So how are we going
to solve this?
What can we do?
And let's not worry
about efficiency.
How could we solve this?
And obviously,
we've been talking
about recursive
algorithms and we've
solved nQueens, which
has lots of combinations.
Sudoku, even more combinations.
There's a lot of
combinations here.
But honestly, the
number of combinations
is dwarfed by the
we've already handled in
these other puzzles, right?
So yeah, so someone wants
to give me some sense of how
this could be done?
Go ahead, Fadi.
AUDIENCE: So if I want
to choose numbers here,
we need to know that
at least there's
going to be a gap between--
at least a gap of one
number between any two
consecutive numbers.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah, you
want a gap of at least one.
AUDIENCE: So what
we can do with that,
we can iterate, for example,
if we have seven numbers,
we have at most four
numbers to pick.
Or, for example, if
we have more numbers,
we then have more options.
If we can do it, we can carry
the gap slice between each two
consecutive numbers
and iterate over that,
and see what combination
gives us the high stuff.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah,
you're basically
trying to create some
sort of exhaustive search.
Your algorithm was
iterating over the gaps.
And there's many
gaps, by the way.
You have a gap of one at
least, and another gap
of one, another gap of one if
I had the strict alternation.
And you have to vary
one of the gaps to two.
And that, obviously, impacts the
numbers you picked even for--
the gap might stay the same
for the next pair of numbers,
but the numbers will be shifted
in the coin row sequence.
And it's fairly complicated, OK?
If you are willing to
give up efficiency,
and you have a set of n items,
then how many different ways,
how many different subsets of
n items do I actually have?
When you have n elements--
you might have learned
this in set algebra.
But if you haven't, we'll
go over it here real quick.
But how many combinations,
how many subsets
do you have when you
have a set of n elements?
You have to count the empty
set and the entire set, right?
So if I, say, have a
set of one element,
then the empty set is a
subset of the one element set.
And then, obviously,
the one element set
is a subset of itself,
so that's two, right?
And then if I had two elements,
A and B, then it's empty,
A, B, and AB.
That's four.
So you get a pattern here?
So it's 2 to the n, right?
So I can generate the 2 to
the n subsets that correspond
to the n-element set.
And there's actually library
functions in Python, powerset,
that lets you do this.
But that's cheating
for this class
because you can't
use libraries, OK?
Real programmers
don't use libraries.
That's actually not true at all.
[LAUGHS] That is probably
the most dishonest statement
made in this course.
Real programmers actually
exploit libraries.
But introductory programmers
should learn programming
by programming from
scratch, right?
But you can generate
the 2 to the n subsets,
for example, by just--
I can show you code
for this offline--
by running through and
incrementing an integer
to go from 0 to 2 raised to n.
You know, 2 raised to
n could be a million,
which is not that bad.
And then this you could encode
as-- you turn it into binary.
So if n happens be 4, then
this turns into 0000, 0001.
And each of these is a
distinct subset, right?
This means none of the
elements are in there.
This means that last
element is in there.
This means that all four
elements are in there.
And somewhere in here, if
you have something like this,
the second one is in there and
the fourth one is in there.
So you could,
essentially, use iteration
to generate all of the subsets.
And you're not done yet.
What do you have to do now that
I've given you all the subsets?
It's two, three lines of
code to solve our problem.
Someone tell me what those
two, three lines of code
are from a standpoint
of operations required.
I'm not looking at
each of the subsets.
What do I need to do
for a given subset?
Yeah, go ahead, Ryan.
AUDIENCE: To iterate
through the subset
and find the sum
of all the values.
SRINI DEVADAS: That's right.
I could iterate
through the subset
and find the sum of
second plus fourth.
I do that for--
do I do that for all the
subsets and pick the maximum?
Or do I do that for a
subset of the subsets
and pick the maximum?
AUDIENCE: from subsets
SRINI DEVADAS: What
happens with this one?
This is picking every number.
So this is obviously
going to be bigger
than all of the other ones.
So did I have to
enumerate all of them?
What is wrong with
this picture here?
what I just said?
AUDIENCE: violates
the constraint.
SRINI DEVADAS: Someone
other than Ganatra,
what is wrong with this solution
which picks all the numbers?
It's on the board, the
answer is on the board.
Yeah, go ahead, Ryan.
AUDIENCE: It violates
the constraint.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah, it
violates the constraint.
So not all of the subsets--
I mean, if all of
the subsets work,
then you don't have to
enumerate all of the subsets.
You would just pick the
numbers, all the numbers, right?
So you have to now check that--
and there is some code, too.
I lied.
I guess, I haven't finished
with my dishonesty.
But it's not two, three lines
of code, it's a little bit more
than that--
to check that particular
subset, whether it violates
the constraints or not.
And so what is the check--
it's going to be four
or five lines of code--
what is the simple check
if I give you a bit string?
What is the simple check that
you need to perform in order
to check the violation of
the constraint in terms
of 0's and 1's?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: No two
consecutive 1's.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah, you
do not do consecutive 1's.
If you ever see two or more
consecutive 1's, you've
got a problem, right?
So that's easy to check.
And this constraint is
no two consecutive 1's.
So you can imagine
coding this up.
And if you coded
that strategy up,
it turns out that this
particular thing, it's
a reasonable strategy
if n is small.
And it turns out that
it would tell you
that you want to pick 15, 23,
4, interesting enough, 17, 34.
So double skip over there
because you would really
want to get to 17.
This 34, and 18,
and you want 15.
That makes sense.
You don't want 12.
And so this ends up
adding up to 126, which
happens to be the optimal.
So you can certainly do that.
You can, as I said,
use the powerset
to save yourself some trouble.
But you still have to code
the violation of constraints,
right?
We want to do substantially
better than this.
Because if n happens to
be a 50, 2 raised to 50
is way too large a number.
And we don't want
to be enumerating
all of these subsets.
In fact, there's a way
of doing this, certainly,
in polynomial time.
And it's going to
be something where
we're going to be able to run
this algorithm in linear time.
We can make a pass
through this list
and get that 126
number blazingly fast
using the notion of
memoization, which is
related to dynamic programming.
And so this is a powerful
algorithmic technique that
you'll see over and over,
especially if you take classes
like 006 and 046.
That gives you exponential
improvements in runtime.
Rather than 2 raised to n,
growing as 2 raised to n,
you grow as n, which is a
huge difference, obviously.
Now, usually, when we talk
about dynamic programming,
we start with a
recursive strategy, not
this enumerative
subset strategy,
to generate the
different solutions.
And one of the
problems with this
is you're generating a
lot of solutions, a lot
of incorrect, invalid subsets.
Because 1111 is
an invalid subset.
And there's a lot of
them that are invalid.
A better approach, which
would still be exponential,
but it is better in terms of
numbers than 2 raised to n,
is to only generate recursively
the legal combinations
and then pick the best
legal combination.
And the legal
combination, of course,
in this case, as
we described, was
no two consecutive 1's, right?
Now, we've done recursion.
We've looked at recursive code.
So the key thing when you write
recursive code is, remember,
you want to get subproblems
that look like the problem
that you're solving, right?
They look exactly like the
problem you're solving.
Because then you
can invoke yourself
as a procedure with
different arguments.
And we kind of went through
this a couple of times.
So this problem is
actually less complicated
than the tiling problem.
It is basically
a row of numbers.
And let's just say you have
numbers a, b, c, d, e, f.
Try to think of a recursive
strategy that says, I want--
let's call it Coinrow.
And Coinrow is going to have
a through f as an argument.
That's the list.
I'm just using pseudocode here.
And I want Coinrow to
do some computation.
And it's going to call
Coinrow maybe multiple times.
But the key thing is,
what are the arguments
that you have inside of those
recursive calls for Coinrow?
And that's the biggest question.
The easier question
to answer is,
what happens when you
have the base case?
And you end up,
essentially, saying,
you've got one coin on the row.
So you've got one
coin problem, right?
What happens then?
What is the base case?
What do you do?
You pick the coin, OK?
Because if you had two
of them, if you happened
to choose the base case to
be 2, in this case, e and f,
what would you do in that case?
Compare the two and pick
the bigger one, right?
But you have to be a
little bit careful here.
Because when you make
the recursive calls,
obviously, you can't have--
would this work if you picked 8?
If I did something like this--
I do 8 plus Coinrow.
So inside here, I do a
plus Coinrow b through f.
If I wrote this code as a
plus Coinrow b through f,
what would happen?
What would happened
if I had Coinrow,
and then I said I'm going to
return a plus Coinrow b through
f, and then I have
a base case that
says that if I have a single--
I still need a base case.
This is just the recursive step.
I need a base case so
this would complete.
And then I say that if I ever
have an argument of length 1,
I'm going to return
that argument.
So what would happen
with this code?
Any ideas?
Go ahead, Kye.
AUDIENCE: Pick all the coins.
SRINI DEVADAS: It would
pick all the coins.
It would just totally
Because it would go a plus,
and then it'd go b through f.
The constraint hasn't been
encoded in here, right?
So we would just
pick all the coins.
So that doesn't make sense.
So I have to--
I have some choices here.
And so this was a giveaway
that this would not work.
Because it's not
doing any choices,
it's just picking all the coins.
So what happens if I pick a?
What does it mean?
If I pick a, what
does that mean?
What does that mean
to my value that I
want to return, which eventually
needs to be the maximum value?
And what does it mean with
respect to the subproblems?
So the first question is easier.
What does it mean with
respect to my value?
I need to add it to
the value, right?
The second question is,
what happens to the--
if I pick a, what happens to the
coin row problem that remains?
What can I say
about the coin row
problem that remains that
you're going to tell me about?
If I picked a--
so this might be
pick the first one.
Pick first, in this
case, which is a.
We'll just put that in brackets.
So what do I need to send
as an argument to Coinrow?
As one possibility, what do
I need to send as an argument
to Coinrow?
Someone who has an answer?
That should use the constraint.
What do I need to send as
an argument to Coinrow?
Yeah, go ahead, I saw Kye first.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: c through f.
SRINI DEVADAS: c
through f, exactly.
I cannot pick b right?
So I encode the constraint
in the recursive call
by saying that if
I picked a then
I encode this as c
dot dot dot f, OK?
I'll just say c dash f.
And let me go ahead and
erase this to give myself
a little bit more room.
But I'm not done yet.
So if I ended up
picking a, and I go--
if I don't write any
more code and I ended up
picking up a plus the value that
I get from Coinrow c through f,
and if I don't
write any more code,
what does that correspond
to in terms of an algorithm?
We've actually used
that algorithm.
What does that correspond to if
I only make one recursive call,
and I pick a, and
I go c through f?
What does that correspond to
with respect to an algorithm?
Someone who hasn't answered?
This is the your last
chance, last lecture.
Yeah, you're thinking about it?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It violates
the constraint
because c and d and e and f.
SRINI DEVADAS: So
Styliani right?
So Styliani says, basically,
it's an alternation algorithm.
You're going to end up picking
a, and then c, and then e,
and then f.
You can't pick f because
you had to skip f.
So it's alternation.
We did this
alternation algorithm.
We knew it wasn't
going to be optimal.
So clearly, it's not a
solution to our problem,
algorithmically speaking,
because it's only
going to give you the
alternating coins.
And that might work out,
but it didn't work out
in the case of our
longer problem, right?
We got-- what was it--
116.
So that doesn't work.
So what else do I do?
What is the other
case that corresponds
do what I have here?
I can pick the coin and?
I could skip the coin.
I could pick the coin and
Skip first, a.
Aha, what now can I pass
into the Coinrow argument?
What can I pass into the
Coinrow argument if I skip a?
Go ahead, Ryan.
AUDIENCE: b through f.
SRINI DEVADAS: b
through f, exactly.
So it's different, b through f.
That's it, that's our algorithm.
This is now four lines of code
in terms of recursive calls.
One last thing, I
did these two things,
I'm going to get values
back for each of these.
Because I'm going
to get a value back.
That's essentially
what I'm doing.
When I'm picking, I'm
going to add the value a.
And then I'm going to add it to
the return value corresponding
to Coinrow c through f.
And then, in this case, I'm
going to get simply the value
corresponding to b through f.
What do I do with val1 and val2?
What do I do with
these two values?
Do I look at them?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: return them?
SRINI DEVADAS: What is the
value for the original-- what
is the value that
I want to return
for the original problem?
Just like with all of
the things we've done,
we've taken values of
subproblems, solutions
to subproblems, and we've
actually done something
with them to return
the value or solution
for the original problem.
So what do I need to do?
What line of code
do I need to write
to return a value for
the original coin row
problem that had a through
f as its arguments?
It's one line of code.
What is that line of code?
Go ahead, George.
AUDIENCE: Put it in the max.
SRINI DEVADAS: Return the max.
That's exactly right.
You return max val1, val2.
And so let me show
you the code for that.
So this is a little bit better
than the subset solution
that we described.
But as it turns out, it's
not a whole lot better,
and we'll talk about that.
But this code now should
not be surprising to you
because we talked about it and
effectively, collectively we
wrote it, right?
That was a collective
coding exercise
called cooperative coding.
Not really, but close enough.
And so you see what
I have up there.
And there's only
one thing that I
didn't describe to you,
which is something that we're
going to get to in a second.
But you see something
called table
in there, which is
essentially something
that keeps the maximum value
corresponding to the smaller
problems that we are looking at.
So it keeps that around.
But you can see that there's a
base case if you forget table.
And there's a reason
that table is in here.
And I'm going to ask
you why in a minute.
But forget about
table for a second.
And if len is 0, you're
going to return 0.
That's a base case.
If len is 1, you're going
to return that coin.
That's also another base case.
And you might end up
with one or the other.
Because, obviously, you're
skipping coins, right?
So it's possible that you
need to take into account
both of these base cases.
You say, why do I
need two base cases?
Well, you're taking away a coin.
So you might end up with
something that's empty, right?
So you need both of
those base cases.
And then pick equals
coin row, table.
This thing over here
is picking the coin.
And then 2 colon says
that you're dropping--
in our case, we picked a, but
we dropped b and started with c.
And skip is you're skipping it.
So you just skipped it
and you go row 1 colon.
Makes perfect sense, right?
And I don't know if you
guys have ever returned--
I think you have in exercises--
if you returned multiple values
in the return statement.
And so this thing
over here is-- the 0
says that I'm going to look at
the first value, not the table.
Because that's a value, and
I'm going to add two values up.
And I'm only concerned
with this value here.
But I'm actually returning
this table thing.
And this table thing, as
you can see from here,
is simply computing
the optimum values
that correspond to problems
of the entire problem
and, essentially, the
problems that are smaller.
And so then you end up--
you're skipping
from the beginning.
And so when you look at
the table len row minus 1,
that is effectively--
since you're going from
the beginning of the list--
that is telling you what the
optimum is, len row minus 1.
Sorry, len row minus 1--
yeah, that's right.
The number of entries in
the table is len raw plus 1.
The total number of entries in
the table starts with 0 always,
so it's len row plus 1.
And so table len
row is the entirety,
that's what you want
for the original thing.
And len row minus 1 looks
at an optimum for that,
skipping the first
one, and so on.
So you're skipping from the
beginning, so remember that.
Why do you think we
have this table in here
if we're only concerned
with the maximum value?
Or are we only concerned
What did I do when I
got these numbers up?
What else did I do other than
pointing out these numbers?
I also gave you more
information, right?
I just said 126.
So if I just told you it was
126, would you believe me?
AUDIENCE: It is hard to check.
SRINI DEVADAS: Well, it's
really hard to check.
It was credible
because I said 126
and then I told you by circling
them what the numbers were,
right?
So if you don't have
this table stuff in here,
it turns out that you don't
have enough information
to figure out what
coins were picked.
You'll get the correct answer.
It is guaranteed to
be a correct answer.
But you don't have the
information about 15,
23, skipping 11
and 3, and getting
4, and so on and so forth.
So we need more code that takes
this collection of subproblems
that each have been solved.
So we actually solved all of
the subproblems corresponding
to picking this, and picking
that, and then picking this,
and so on and so forth.
And you need to use
those values in order
to discover, using a traceback
procedure, what the coins are.
Or you could do
more work in here.
I chose to-- you'll see why--
I chose to do it this way where
I'm collecting up everything
into table.
And I'm going to
eventually-- and we'll
talk about this code,
at least briefly.
But this code, traceback, is
taking the original problem
and a table and is just
iteratively going through--
there's no
enumeration here, this
is very efficient--
is iteratively
going through row and
table and discovering
what the selected coins are.
And so that's something that
we'll look at in just a minute.
Actually not just a minute,
but after we go back to this.
And I'm going to
tell you or ask you
about this in terms of its
computational complexity, OK?
So anyway, assume that
we've done traceback.
And it's not hard to do if
you have the table of results.
Then let's go back
to this and let's
talk about the recursive calls.
And let's take a look at what's
going on here with respect
to how many recursive
calls are made.
And then we'll
get to memoization
in dynamic programming.
So let me just say,
if I had Coins that--
this is the number of elements--
so I have 5.
Then I'm going to call Coins 4
and I'm going to call Coins 3.
And so here, I
skipped the first one.
Here, I picked the first
one, and therefore, I
had to skip the second one,
so I have 3 here, right?
That makes sense?
And then over here,
what do I need
to write here if I follow
exactly the pattern?
I'm going to write
Coins 3, right?
So I have Coins 3 over here,
and here, it's Coins 2.
And here, I'm just going
to write the numbers down--
2, 1.
And again, I've got
2, 1, and so on.
Now, the base case--
you might keep going even after
2 because the base cases are--
you go 1, 0, 1, 0.
What do you see in here
that's a little bothersome?
What do you see here
that's bothersome?
What is that, symbolically?
If I had some number of
elements, n elements,
what do I put here?
It's n, right?
And what do you see here?
It's getting pretty big.
So down here, it's
getting pretty big.
So that's the problem.
And one of the reasons
it's getting pretty big
is because you're doing
work over and over.
You see, Coins 3 here
couple of places,
Coins 2 in three places.
And if this were larger,
you'd see a lot of subproblems
being solved over and over.
So this code that you
see up on the screen
is incredibly
inefficient because it's
solving the same problem
over and over, OK?
In particular, you would
solve Coins 4 exactly once,
but Coins 3 twice,
Coins 2 three times.
And if I just went up and
made this 10, Coins 10,
then you would see things
that are solved tens of times.
And eventually,
you'll see things that
are solved hundreds of times.
You're just repeating
work over and over.
You can actually write a
recurrence relationship
that says that if you
had an n-element coin row
problem, then your
recurrence corresponds
to the number of
calls that are made.
Number of operations
therefore that are performed
is A n equals A n minus
1 plus A n minus 2.
And then the base cases are
A0 equals 1 and A1 equals 1,
because you're
just picking that.
And so if you look at
what A2 would be, A2 is 2.
But then A3 is 2 plus--
initially it grows
fairly slowly.
But then, when you get to
A4, it becomes 5, and so on.
And have you seen this number
before, this recurrence
relationship before?
It's called Fibonacci.
It's called the
Fibonacci recurrence,
and this actually shows up here.
So this has a
relationship to Fibonacci.
And the number of computations
in a recursive Fibonacci
is exactly the same
as in this problem.
But if I told you to compute
the Fibonacci number F of n,
can you do that quickly?
If I wanted for you just to
compute the Fibonacci number,
then you would just
do that iteratively
like I'm doing here, right?
The numbers would get
bigger, but there's
no reason to do exponential
work for Fibonacci.
But here, of course, we're
doing something much more
sophisticated than
just Fibonacci,
in the sense that we are
working with a coin row problem.
But this should give you a
sense of the efficiency that
is possible here by thinking
about the relationship
between recursive
Fibonacci that would
look a lot like this
structure that you see here--
just calling Fib of n.
Sorry, for Fib of n, you're
calling Fib of n minus 1
and you're calling Fib
of n minus 2 recursively,
you're adding them up.
And the base cases
are exactly the same
as you have here, returning
for the 0 case, F 0,
you're returning 1,
and so on and so forth.
And even Fibonacci,
you end up having
redundancy in the recursive
formulation, which
is exactly the redundancy
that you see here, OK?
And so basically, it
turns out that if you want
to go exponential to linear--
and you kind of see
where this is going.
The recursive was exponential.
The iterative, in the case
of Fibonacci, is linear.
So two things-- one,
you can take this
and you can turn it into
iteration and make it linear.
But that is actually a more
dramatic transformation
of the code.
You can do something that
is equivalent in efficiency
to the iterative version--
both for Fibonacci and
for our coin row problem,
and we'll do it for
our coin row problem--
that corresponds to,
as I said, the more
local modification
of this code that
eliminates redundancy,
that eliminates
redundant computations.
And all of these
things are equivalent
and they're all part
of dynamic programming.
And we have four lectures on
dynamic programming in 006.
So in 10 minutes or
15 minutes, you're
just going to get some sense
for what this is all about.
And so this is really a
preview or an elevator pitch
perhaps, a trailer, right?
So you end up, essentially,
doing equivalent work
in the recursive memoized
version of this code
that I'll show you
in just a minute that
adds three lines of code to
this and makes the complexity go
from exponential to linear.
And all you do in this code
that makes this complexity
equivalent into the iterative
and that's very efficient
is you remember the results.
You memoize the results
of the computation.
And you remember
that you've solved
Coins 4, which doesn't
really help you
in this particular instance.
But you remember that
you've solved Coins 3,
so you don't end up
doing all of this work.
You end up just saying, OK--
I'm sorry, it depends on
which direction you went.
Let's say that, for
argument's sake,
you went in this
direction first, OK?
It totally depends on which
direction you went first.
And since I drew this out and
I don't want to change it,
let's just assume that you
went in terms of Coins 3 first.
Which, in fact, is correct
in terms of the code
because if you see
what I have there,
I went in the pick
direction first, which
meant that I would go ahead
and pick that first value.
And then I'd go in the right
direction, the right-hand side
direction.
So if I did all of that,
I do all of this work,
now there's also memoization
going on inside of here.
So it's not like I'm
doing all of this work.
I'm not only getting
it just a factor of 2
in terms of improvement.
But definitely, once I do
this and I get the value,
I can just return
that value here
and I don't have to do all
the work underneath this.
That's why I put
this in a square, OK?
And remember that this is
being done recursively.
So I'm going to
do it for Coins 2.
And so if I had multiple
Coins 2's, then I
wouldn't have to do that.
And then over here, if I had
a longer coin row problem
to begin with, there's a lot
of memoization that goes on.
And you end up only solving--
this is the key--
you end up only solving each
subproblem how many times?
Once.
Now the aha moment.
How many subproblems are there?
How many coin row problems are
there, given an n-element coin
raw problem?
How many?
All of you together.
How many coin row
problems are there?
n, that's it.
There's only n
coin row problems.
It's like you had a through
f, you had b through f,
you had c through f, you had d
through f, you had e, f, and f.
So if you only solve
coin row problem once,
and there's only n
coin row problems,
the complexity clearly
cannot be exponential,
it's going to be linear.
Because whatever work
you did for that problem
is all that you have to do.
And so maybe there's
a constant factor.
But let's say that the number
of operations-- obviously,
this is just the max.
It's not complicated.
We know what that is.
So it would be the
complexity of solving
a subproblem times the
number of subproblems.
The complexity of solving
a subproblem is constant.
It's just a small
number of operations.
And the number of
subproblems is linear.
So it's linear time,
which is exactly the same
as the iterative version.
This is an incredibly
powerful notion,
which is why there's
classes on this topic, just
this very topic.
And we spend a lot of time on
this in 006 as well as 046.
So what I'm going to do,
the main thing I want to do
is show you this code that is
an incremental modification
of the code I showed you before
that takes this complexity
and turns it from
exponential to linear using
this notion of memoization.
And then I want to tell you a
little bit about the traceback
code because that's interesting.
But from a standpoint of
just getting the value back,
you're all good without even
understanding traceback.
So all I've done here
is I've taken table
and I've turned it
into a dictionary, OK?
And I had to do a
little bit of work
here with respect
to the memoization.
So if I look at the
base cases, it's
pretty much exactly the same.
I just have a memo in a table.
And all of these are
essentially the same.
I'm sorry, all of these up
here are essentially the same.
And then I'm looking at
a particular problem.
I see whether the memo
table that I have--
if len row in memo, then
if it's in the dictionary,
that means I've already
seen this problem before.
And I just return the values
stored in that dictionary.
And the value stored in that
dictionary is, essentially,
a pair which corresponds to not
just the value of the problem,
but also I'm storing--
I'm sorry, I take that back.
So memo itself is
just like table.
This memo here is
simply because overall I
want to return both the
value and the memo table.
So this memo table is exactly
like the original table.
It's simply a set of key-value
pairs that go memo 5 equals 56,
memo 4 maybe equals
42, et cetera.
So that's just a
simple memo table.
And I just need to
return the memo.
And so that's why I
had this memo out here.
And this looks exactly
the same as it did before.
These three lines
are exactly the same.
This is an important line.
So these lines were
added because I
wanted to memoize and look
up what I solved before.
And this line was added--
well, added in the sense
that it was added for memo,
but I already had it for table.
So it's just a
simple replacement,
so perhaps I shouldn't
have said added.
But this is
important because I'm
putting it into the memo table.
And it's really this if
statement that's the key.
Don't do redundant work.
So if you get to
this if statement,
you're obviously getting
to a return, which
means you're not making
these recursive calls, which
is exactly going over here and
remembering that you solved
Coins 3 and returning
the value of Coins 3
the moment you see it.
All right?
That makes sense?
Everybody is good with that?
Excellent.
Let's just run this.
And I want to show you
what this gives you
just so you get some
sense of what's going on.
There's a couple of
different problems
and I'm running them
with the different code.
And so you're getting
the same answers.
That's just for
verification purposes.
So if you focus in
on what happens here,
this is, essentially, solving
our first smaller problem.
And it's telling you that if
you have the entire problem
with the seven
coins, which is what
I have up there, the
first problem here,
then what you have is 56.
And if, in fact, you
ended up dropping-- it
you're looking at the subproblem
that goes from 3 to 1,
and you drop 14, the optimum
value for that is 42.
And then, if you drop both 14
and 3, and you went with that,
then you need to go
backwards from here--
56, 42.
It's still 42.
So if you drop 14, it's 42.
If you drop 3, it's still 42
because 27 and 15 give you
your 42.
And that makes sense.
And so you can see that.
And then this other thing
here is the bigger problem.
It says, table equals--
sorry, yikes, Python shell.
Let me just point
with the cursor.
This large thing here
is our bigger problem.
And you can see the
table for this--
126.
If you dropped the first
one, you'd still get 126.
Then if you drop the
first two, 3 and 15,
you get, obviously, a smaller
result, and so on and so forth.
And this table that
I'm getting back,
which is basically the
original table that you could
be thinking of as a list,
that turned into a dictionary
when I wanted to memoize
because I wanted to look it up
very efficiently.
I could have left it, in
this case, as a Python list.
I did not need to
use a dictionary.
I didn't need the
generality of a dictionary
where the indices to a list can
be strings or negative numbers.
I'm just indexing into this.
So the dictionary is a
bit of a red herring.
I just happened to use it.
But in general, you
use dictionaries
because you may have
to look up things
that are more complicated
than just integer values.
But here, I could just
number the subproblems
0 through 7, what have you,
and then just look it up.
So the bottom line is I need
that information in order
to compute or figure out
what coins were selected.
And so the last thing
that I will show you
is the traceback routine, which
I just put up there briefly.
But I just want to
spend one minute on this
and we will close.
And this traceback routine is
taking the values that you saw
and figuring out whether
you picked a coin or not.
So what it does is it
looks at the entire thing
and it knows that the
entire thing is 56.
And then it says, if I drop
the first one, and I get 42.
And it compares 56 with 42
and says, wait a minute,
the difference there is 14.
And that is exactly the value
of the first element, right?
So what this tells me is that
if I had the original problem,
I got 56.
If I drop the first one,
I get 42 as optimal.
So that implies that for
the original problem,
I picked the first coin.
Because 56 minus 42
is 14, that's it.
That's pretty much
all you have to do.
You just have to do
that over and over.
And it's a little bit
more complicated than that
only because you don't want
to get into negative indices
for tables.
And so the only reason
that first line-- table len
row minus i equals
equals raw i-- is there
is for the corner case where
you have a single-element list.
And you don't want to get
into a situation where--
this thing here
cannot be negative.
If this is negative,
then the program crashes.
So you don't want to
get to this statement.
It becomes negative, and
it's a degenerate case.
And you don't want to get there.
This or takes care of that.
You essentially check for
the singleton equality.
And then you don't fall
through the second--
if this part of the
statement is true,
then this doesn't get computed.
So if table len row i
equals equals row i is true,
then you don't compute that,
you don't get a negative index,
and everything works on.
But it comes down to
56 minutes 42 is 14,
and you're all good to go.
All right, good.
So that's all I had, well, for
this lecture, for the class.
I'm going to be co-lecturing
6006 next semester.
I notice that some of
you were preregistered,
so I guess it's not goodbye.
But it doesn't have to be
goodbye for the rest of you.
You know what I said--
happy to talk algorithms
and computer science.
Thanks for being an
attentive audience.
[APPLAUSE]